demi lovato says she is not talking to
Selena Gomez or the Jonas Brothers
anymore One Direction is reuniting for
their 10th anniversary Northwest crashes
her mom's PSA and the celeb couples they
are going to extremes in quarantine this
is 80 live at home we need to get into
this t because it has me a little shook
but also kind of sad and disappointed
Demi Lovato right you just did an
interview with Harper's Bazaar when she
was asked about her relationships or
lack thereof I should say with Selena
Gomez and Jonas Brothers you know her
pals from her Disney days and her answer
was kind of surprising yes so basically
hearing that she is not friends with
Selena Gomez anymore was a dagger right
to the heart because these girls grew up
together from Barney days grown adults
and everything in between
rising to stardom both on their own
tracks also being in the Disney family
also being you know almost like family
members to each other their moms were
friends their families were friends the
siblings it's just it's obviously as you
grow up as an adult you know people come
and go in your lives but I thought that
Barbie friendship would be forever I was
a little surprised because we saw after
Demi made her big comeback at the
Grammys this past year was she's sing
her new single it was really emotional
where everyone was rooting for her and
Selena actually reposted that honor in
stories throwing her support at her and
they actually asked Demi about that and
she says when you grow up with someone
you're always gonna have love for them
but I'm not friends with her
so if felt da and the reporter says
that's when she kind of like paused and
then moved on and said I will always
have love for her and I wish everybody
nothing but the best I feel like there
was something she wanted to say but she
like you know what this is not the place
for it and I wonder what it is that put
that strain obviously Demi went through
her own life stuff and Selena of course
as well and her own health scares and
struggles but like you're right because
of their history and that little Grammy
moment too I was like oh like women
still supporting women in the industry
Oh
Selena Gomez no matter what will always
you know be representative of that
female empowerment but I think it would
be more so if she didn't say anything
fans would pick up and I'm talking about
Selena here and then also with Demi what
she said you know she didn't need to go
into detail when she said quote when you
grow up with somebody you're always
going to have loved them I'm not friends
with her so it felt that's all she
needed to say for everyone to you know
feel that heartbreak right there and
know that they're not she don't need to
go into detail she literally explicitly
said we're not friends anymore you know
I don't think we will ever know really
what happened behind closed doors to be
honest with you I really don't think
these two women had any I don't think
there was like an issue person I think
it was just really a case of maybe
adults going their separate ways and not
maintaining that friendship and you know
I really don't think there's like one
particular issue like a man or something
like that no I don't think there was
like a falling now yeah I don't think
there's like a falling now and I want to
I want to say that like it's also hard
when you're reading these interviews in
print like it's all quotes right I
almost wonder if she just meant
technically like as a technicality
friends you know we don't call each
other we're not checking in on each
other all the time we don't hang out
like that's what you do a friend that's
true right well you know we're checking
in with their friends were facetiming
we're texting so maybe they don't have
that connection anymore and that's what
she means by we're no longer friends but
I do believe what she says I still have
love for her obviously but the Jonas
Brothers too though obviously Demi has
collaborated what you know better than
anybody that she's collaborated with the
Joe Broz so many times I could have camp
rock films and when she was asked about
whether she'd not she keeps in touch
with the Joe Broz the reporter says she
just shook her head no simply and put it
at that to be honest with you I'm very
surprised about Selena I'm not surprised
about the Jonas Brothers believe think
of the Jonas Brothers and Demi Lovato in
what that chapter of these boys meant to
her that
that was a huge chunk of her past that
she might want to forget because of all
of the hardship that she was going
through she was struggling with her you
know alcohol abuse and drug abuse during
that chapter when they were on tour
together she obviously had her own
personal relationships you know with Joe
Jonas at the time and what doing maybe
that's just a chapter that she wants to
close and then again I mean people
people move on and go their separate
ways and obviously all three of the boys
are married now
you know kevin has a family now that I
don't think she was like the closest
with Kevin anyway but you know they all
have their own lives they're married and
you know it's just it's it's sad but
it's life that people you know grow
apart it happens right and it's
definitely something she confronted
literally head-on and directly and I
love me video remember we saw those like
that she's in the Jonas Brothers she
don't talk to you anymore
Selena Gomez she's not friends with them
anymore but my that was you know in the
in this Harper's Bazaar spread she
really says that Miley is the only
person from the Disney era that she
actually keeps in touch with she says
quote she's awesome and I love her to
death and always will always have but I
think she's the only one from the era I
will stay in touch with her I still stay
in touch with um I wonder I really
wonder why that is with the Joe Broz in
particular I wonder if it's because you
know obviously they are managed by her
former manager what does it feel
McIntyre and she's of course since moved
on with Scooter Braun so maybe it's also
like a business thing that's driving up
newlyweds like not not that it's the
cause of anything but that it's like
pushing her further apart from them
because of course she also goes on to
say that her relationship with ariana
grande grande who's also managed by
Scooter Braun has strengthened as she
says I love the fact that Ari and I have
such a supportive friendship because
it's hard to find two women who are in a
competitive industry the whole world
seems to want to pit women against each
other so it would be easy to do that but
she goes you know I've always
appreciated like her relationships with
females
which I thought was interesting to know
after just saying that she's no longer
talking to Celina either you know but at
least she has some friends in the
industry still you know there's that
saying that I feel like our family's
always told us growing up especially in
those high school days it's better to
have what is it it's better to have one
dime than ten pennies you know go
through friends and circles of groups of
people you figure out who you want next
you in the long haul and then when you
have someone like Demi Lovato who has
been through a lot in her personal life
when you go through something as
traumatic as you know her overdose and
2,080 on you realize also then in times
like that who really has your back who
does not have ulterior ulterior motives
who really is going to and maybe she saw
people's true colors then I don't know
someone who knows that better than
anybody how relationships can even flow
change one minute you're together with
me or not is one direction it it looks
like the guys have finally put the past
behind them because the source tells et
that one D that means all five guys are
playing on reuniting for the 10th
anniversary of the band forming which is
so exciting because obviously ever since
the Zane drama ever since I feel like
they never came back from that they put
out a really album with just the four of
them without saying that was amazing
they would you sold millions records
went on this massive world tour but I
think fans always felt like oh that one
piece is missing
well yes literally that one beast that
one person in one direction but I just
love that you know obviously they are
all grown men they've gone on their own
adventures as solo artists and they've
had tremendous success but he recognized
that they would not be where they are
right now if it works for those fans so
doing something significant
the ten-year anniversary you know
obviously we don't know what it is
exactly right now they're our source
tells us that you know due to the Copa
19 outbreak due to other factors of
everyone being in different locations
and then also the fear factor that each
person each artist has different
management and labels they're not able
to like come together yet on something
concrete but they know that they need
and want to do something special for
their fans which is really nice and I
love that they're not gonna like go the
Spice Girls route and then like have a
posh not be involved like I love that
they're all coming together my light
just went out so you have to forgive oh
there it is this comes after the guys
have said that they're down for a union
like Harry Styles to Rolling Stones now
told James Corden Simon Cowell told me
he's like in five or ten years I
remember what the time was but he said I
guarantee one direction will reunite for
somebody is inevitable do you think
though that it'll be something that
sticks or is it just gonna be this like
reunion special thing for the 10th
anniversary like is Zayn down to be part
of the group again I think it's gonna be
a one-time thing you have people like
Niall was just about to embark on this
you know solo huge tour for himself and
then also Harry Styles doing the same
thing yeah yeah I don't think
schedule-wise logistically they're going
to be able to do a full One Direction
revamp right now I think they're gonna
do something really sweet and intimate
for their fans for the 10 year
anniversary and then see how that goes
because I feel like it's something that
the fans are gonna go nuts over and it's
gonna be the truth that's and you know
you you want to keep that going
obviously so I think that there is
potential but I think in the meantime
it's gonna be like this huge one-time
thing oh my god look through reuniting
and then let that simmer and then have
conversations in the background and then
surprise us with something fans are so
stoked like there is so multiple 1d
hashtags trending they all decide to hop
on the same playlist and play it at the
same time in honor of the guys but more
importantly they spotted
all the guys started following Zayn
again which I live for that the
Directioners have they definitely have a
leg up on you and I we are good with our
CIA FBI investigation I respect stands
and fandoms so hard because they're the
information that no one else could get
so guys guys notice everything from the
boy is following Zayn again to the fact
that the official website for the group
is like reactivated and there's a
twenty20 copyright which I know time is
kind of frozen right now but I know we
are at 20:20 and the header on their
Twitter account apparently changed too I
mean the signs are there there do you
remember their Instagram account all of
a sudden the profile was black and then
they they just revamped everything and
then a couple weeks later it was
confirmed it was official to the loaf to
the whole of all I have to say it is
that - that is I'm looking at you
Destiny's Child where you at let's get
it together ladies come on now Coachella
wasn't enough for me I was going to say
[Music]
I talked to mama Tina about this and she
listened she I'm a good body language
pretty sure she pretty sure she pigs
that it will happen one day
uh-oh I'm putting it out in the universe
okay it's time go on tour ladies I need
to see you okay uh let's talk about
Northwest because obviously she's
quarantine II with her parents
Kim and Kanye and her siblings but I
think North is still dying of attention
she is so over her siblings and she is
it literally literally attached at the
hip of her mom Kim she Bobby she won't
leave her alone here's further proof
this is north
crashing Kim's PSA about social
distancing okay so guys we just fly you
to social distance there's so many fun
amazing projects you can do you can
spend time with your kids and have so
much fun trust me I want to get out more
than you know it's really important to
also do mental health checks on your
friends your loved ones facts
Kim literally cannot get away from her
she's gonna have to upgrade her mansion
so she can figure out even more rooms to
hide in she literally just posted a
video of you don't know a few days ago
drink your makeup in like a guest
bathroom her kids would not leave very
loud mus why sweetie okay
can you Dorothy can you do it in the
other room move in the middle of
something I don't want to get this all
wet sweetie
I'm hiding in the guest room you guys
I'm hiding in the guest room because my
kids all I want to do is this makeup
tutorial please can I have like three
minutes of North was like well that's me
serious PSA head north is like peeking
around the corner she loves the bright
lights daddy does and you can't blame
her either because you know you have to
realize that a lot of these kids are not
used to having their parents like at
home all the time and so everywhere
right and there's no camera crews also
when your parents are around like it's a
treat right I can only imagine like
you're used to having fun with them when
they come home from work or whatever and
so now it's like they feel like it's
playtime I need to be entertain and
stimulated the entire time but I would
I'm not a parent obviously but I would
be Kim but I also don't have a mansion
where I can run and play like I would be
going mad I mean I hate to say it but
it's sure talked about the power of the
Kardashians I mean these are Kardashian
Jenner's I should say this family it's
like if you say if they say jump people
are like how high because not only did
you know the governor of
you know recruit kidding to do this PSA
but you also have the Surgeon General
recruiting kindly to you know speak to
her fans and encourage people to stay at
home and practice social distancing it's
mine I mean that's I mean I guess that's
the whole word influencer influence
people to do and here they are talking
to their millions of fans you know it's
but it's also like really is that what
it took we needed a Kardashian to remind
honestly yes I'm like multiple millions
of followers combined like do it okay
what now whatever it takes to get us out
of here faster you know like there's a
lot of a lot of people stepping up but
we appreciate health care workers
everybody the people our grocery stores
people delivering our food but listen
those people don't have 27 million
followers on Instagram like Kim lead the
way just so we can go on with our some
acts okay
cast we got to move on and talk about
your boy Blake Shelton yes he's rocking
a very outrageous haircut courtesy of
Gwen what did you think you know what I
listened it's just hair it will grow
back Blake could have zero hair and he
would still look good because you know
what it's about the inside that matters
and he is from you know first-hand
experience he's one of the nicest
funniest most down-to-earth people I've
ever met my entire life and so I really
think he could do no wrong when it comes
to the appearance but I'm gonna mole it
but he is country and that is that is
prying country right there and some
bullet and I love that he's I love that
he's it's a time right now to be
creative I mean hello I'm wearing like a
hot pink magenta lip just because you
can try whatever you want right now
Wednesday Pawnee gave him stripes not
too long ago we saw those they posted it
on Twitter and you know now they're
taking it to the next look like this is
like this is the thing during foreign
team I mean people they've been laughs
together
on his land for you know weeks now now
and they're just you know Keith
he said Gwen nobody went you with the
Clippers ah plug their song wait
speaking of them quarantine in Oklahoma
together like they're loving it you can
tell on social media and her popping up
on his Instagram live with all these
cute flirty but our source also told the
et that then gain away from the city
into Oklahoma during like while we're
all practicing social disesteem was like
the right call for them and they're
enjoying the time with the kids and he's
always loved bringing them to Oklahoma
they're like fishing and doing all this
up doors II stuff I'm like of course
that's like their second home I think
the quarantine was exactly what Gwen and
Blake wanted and it's probably for the
family I'm kind of jealous but I'm not
jealous of that moley
I am so sorry like you know walk around
with your guitar and country words what
though I wouldn't rock a full-face beat
though did you see this Cody Simpson he
is shutting down any signs of toxic
masculinity because he let Miley give
him a full face beat pretty or not he
went for it uh and also was like teasing
these like steamy new photos with Miley
like this whole photo shoot they did you
talk about getting creative during
quarantine they're really good he's
given me a run for my money though I
mean he went sold BAM did you see his
highlighter it could fly it could shine
to outer space
it was poppin it was poppin have you let
your boyfriend I do anything like
maintenance wise I mean I've said this a
million times on et live at home but he
did cut my hair like the sides of it uh
also this is gonna sound silly but you
know I recently got my ear pierced like
this past year right
I know but I finally am able to like
switch out the ring it's like except I
couldn't get this off like right now I
have the little stud and it was so hard
to get I'm not used to jewelry or
earrings and so I literally couldn't put
it take it off and I couldn't put it
back on I use his help I learn his help
over here what is daddy good at changes
ear piercing too you can see that I'm
wearing gray sweat still could you up
you're gonna hate it
but I got you hate the earring you hated
it you're like I hate change I got a
little dangly feather guy she's leaving
I just want another fool I wanted a
little Rufio moment I think I don't
we're not I actually did this is gonna
sound dumb but again what else we gonna
do I think it's go to go I did this for
couch Shella actually is what I was
trying to say like I bought it for last
week you want to give yourself a mullet
by all means go ahead go do that to you
do you know you do you - I know you had
a real honor roommate - take out your
extensions oh that was the first day of
quarantine I gave her the pliers and we
actually literally lifted my hair and
loosened up the extensions I'm embracing
all natural right now says the woman
who's got 9-inch lashes on her break
when I'm not doing this like it is full
face mask skin care hair care putting
the mask everything the only thing
that's I mean my nails are all-natural
but I mean they bent them to the court
they look nasty
oh my god the I talk to Rita Ora she
misses gained her nails done and was
heating the natural hair I've spoken to
Karly Pierce
everyone's like oh my god my nails but I
luckily didn't do like I never have done
gel just because I I like to do my own
nails and my budget wise I'm like I'm
gonna do it myself so I lucked out and
was 14 I didn't have to remove anything
well listen and you embrace the on that
trial while you can because we'll go
back to normal pretty soon all right I
am on low battery for this laptop's lift
move on to the last story
okay this family is 6 in Washington
speaking of getting creative
they'd her little bored cooped up at
home during quarantine and so they took
it upon themselves to recreate journeys
1983 music video four separate ways and
it's so epic take a look
[Music]
[Music]
what I really lifted my spirits we hope
it lifted your guyses - that does it for
today's easy live at home Cassie I miss
you so much
let me tell you I know I used to be like
attached at your hip near the Ottoman
I'm like you may run but you can't hide
from me I'll be all over you
you're my Northwest I'm gonna be able to
shake you and that's okay
all right well you guys thanks for
tuning and make sure you stick with ET
live and of course here on ET live
YouTube channel or a whole lot more
during quarantine left y'all Wow
[Music]